OPERATOR: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So let's start.
I have written a number
on the board here.
Anyone want to speculate what
that number represents?
Well, you may recall at the end
of the last lecture, we
were simulating pi, and I
started up running it with a
billion darts.
And when it finally terminated,
this was the
estimate of pi it gave
me with a billion.
Not bad, not quite perfect,
but still pretty good.
In fact when I later ran it with
10 billion darts, which
took a rather long time to run,
didn't do much better.
So it's converging very slowly
now near the end.
When we use an algorithm like
that one to perform a Monte
Carlo simulation, we're
trusting, as I said, that fate
will give us an unbiased sample,
a sample that would be
representative of true
random throws.
And, indeed in this case,
that's a pretty good
assumption.
The random number generator is
not truly random, it's what's
called pseudo-random, in that if
you start it with the same
initial conditions, it will
give you the same results.
But it's close enough for, at
least for government work, and
other useful projects.
We do have to think about the
question, how many samples
should we run?
Was a billion darts enough?
Now since we sort of all started
knowing what pi was,
we could look at it and say,
yeah, pretty good.
But suppose we had no clue about
the actual value of pi.
We still have to
think about the
question of how many samples?
And also, how accurate do we
believe our result is, given
the number of samples?
As you might guess, these two
questions are closely related.
That, if we know in advance how
much accuracy we want, we
can sometimes use that
to calculate how
many samples we need.
But there's still always
the issue.
It's never possible
to achieve perfect
accuracy through sampling.
Unless you sample the
entire population.
No matter how many samples you
take, you can never be sure
that the sample set is typical
until you've checked every
last element.
So if I went around MIT and
sampled 100 students to try
and, for example, guess the
fraction of students at MIT
who are of Chinese descent.
Maybe 100 students would be
enough, but maybe I would get
unlucky and draw
the wrong 100.
In the sense of, by accident,
100 Chinese descent, or 100
non-Chinese descent,
which would give
me the wrong answer.
And there would be no way I
could be sure that I had not
drawn a biased sample, unless
I really did have the whole
population to look at.
So we can never know that
our estimate is correct.
Now maybe I took a billion
darts, and for some reason got
really unlucky and they
all ended up inside
or outside the circle.
But what we can know, is how
likely it is that our answer
is correct, given
the assumptions.
And that's the topic we'll spend
the next few lectures
on, at least one
of the topics.
It's saying, how can we know
how likely it is that our
answer is good.
But it's always given some set
of assumptions, and we have to
worry a lot about those
assumptions.
Now in the case of our pi
example, our assumption was
that the random number generator
was indeed giving us
random numbers in the
interval 0 to 1.
So that was our underlying
assumption.
Then using that, we looked at a
plot, and we saw that after
time the answer wasn't
changing very much.
And we use that to say, OK, it
looks like we're actually
converging on an answer.
And then I ran it again, with
another trial, and it
converged again at
the same place.
And the fact that that happened
several times led me
to at least have some reason to
believe that I was actually
finding a good approximation
of pi.
That's a good thing to do.
It's a necessary thing to do.
But it is not sufficient.
Because errors can creep
into many places.
So that kind of technique,
and in fact, almost all
statistical techniques, are good
at establishing, in some
sense, the reproduce-ability of
the result, and that it is
statistically valid, and that
there's no error, for example,
in the way I'm generating
the numbers.
Or I didn't get very unlucky.
However, they're other places
other than bad luck where
errors can creep in.
So let's look at an
example here.
I've taken the algorithm we
looked at last time for
finding pi, and I've
made a change.
You'll remember that we were
before using 4 as our
multiplier, and here what I've
done is, just gone in and
replaced 4 by 2.
Assuming that I made a
programming error.
Now let's see what happens
when we run it.
Well, a bad thing
has happened.
Sure enough, we ran it and
it converged, started to
converge, and if I ran 100
trials each one would converge
at roughly the same place.
Any statistical test I would
do, would say that my
statistics are sound, I've
chosen enough samples, and for
some accuracy, it's
converting.
Everything is perfect,
except for what?
It's the wrong answer.
The moral here, is that just
because an answer is
statistically valid, does not
mean it's the right answer.
And that's really important to
understand, because you see
this, and we'll see more
examples later, not today, but
after Thanksgiving, comes
up all the time in the
newspapers, in scientific
articles, where people do a
million tests, do all the
statistics right, say here's
the answer, and it turns out
to be completely wrong.
And that's because it was some
underlying assumption that
went into the decision,
that was not true.
So here, the assumption is,
that I've done my algebra
right for computing pi based
upon where the darts land.
And it turns out, if I put 2
here, my algebra is wrong.
Now how could I discover this?
Since I've already told you
no statistical test is
going to help me.
What's the obvious thing I
should be doing when I get
this answer?
Somebody?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Checking against reality.
I started with the notion that
pi had some relation to the
area of a circle.
So I could use this value
of pi, draw a
circle with a radius.
Do my best to measure
the area.
I wouldn't need to get a very
good, accurate measurement,
and I would say, whoa, this
isn't even close.
And that would tell me
I have a problem.
So the moral here is,
to check results
against physical reality.
So for example, the current
problem set, you're doing a
simulation about what
happens to viruses
when drugs are applied.
If you were doing this for a
pharmaceutical company, in
addition to the simulation,
you'd want to run some real
experiments.
And make sure that
things matched.
OK, what this suggests, is that
we often use simulation,
and other computational
techniques, to try and model
the real world, or the
physical world, in
which we all live.
And we can use data
to do that.
I now want to go through another
set of examples, and
we're going to look at the
interplay of three things:
what happens when you have data,
say from measurements,
and models that at least claim
to explain the data.
And then, consequences that
follow from the models.
This is often the way science
works, its the way engineering
works, we have some
measurements, we have a theory
that explains the measurements,
and then we
write software to explore the
consequences of that theory.
Including, is it plausible
that it's really true?
So I want to start, as
an example, with a
classic chosen from 8.01.
So I presume, everyone
here has taken 8.01?
Or in 8.01?
Anyone here who's not had
an experience with 801?
All right, well.
I hope you know about springs,
because we're going to talk
about springs.
So if you think about it, I'm
now just talking not about
springs that have water in them,
but springs that you
compress, you know, and expand,
and things like that.
And there's typically something
called the spring
constant that tells us how stiff
the spring is, how much
energy it takes to compress
this spring.
Or equivalently, how much pop
the spring has when you're no
longer holding it down.
Some springs are easy to
stretch, they have a small
spring constant.
Some strings, for example,
the ones that hold up an
automobile, suspension,
are much harder
to stretch and compress.
There's a theory about them
called Hooke's Law.
And it's quite simple.
Force, the amount of force
exerted by a spring, is equal
to minus some constant times
the distance you have
compressed the spring.
It's minus, because the force
is exerted in an opposite
direction, trying
to spring up.
So for example, we could
look at it this way.
We've got a spring, excuse
my art here.
And we put some weight on the
spring, which has therefore
compressed it a little bit.
And the spring is exerting
some upward force.
And the amount of force it's
exerting is proportional to
the distance x.
So, if we believe Hooke's Law,
and I give you a spring, how
can we find out what
this constant is?
Well, we can do it by putting a
weight on top of the spring.
It will compress the spring a
certain amount, and then the
spring will stop moving.
Now gravity would normally have
had this weight go all
the way down to the bottom,
if there was no spring.
So clearly the spring is
exerting some force in the
upward direction, to keep that
mass from going down to the
table, right?
So we know what that
force is there.
If we compress the spring to a
bunch of different distances,
by putting, say, different size
weights on it, we can
then solve for the spring
constant, just the way,
before, we solved for pi.
So it just so happens, not quite
by accident, that I've
got some data from a spring.
So let's look at it.
So here's some data taken
from measuring a spring.
This is distance and force,
force computed from the mass,
basically, right?
Because we know that these
have to be in balance.
And I'm not going to ask you to
in your head estimate the
constant from these, but what
you'll see is, the format is,
there's a distance, and then a
colon, and then the force.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Ok, right,
yes, thank you.
All right, want to repeat that
more loudly for everyone?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, right, because
the x in the equation
-- right, here we're getting
an equilibrium.
OK, so let's look at what
happens when we try and
examine this.
We'll look at spring dot pi.
So it's pretty simple.
First thing is, I've got a
function that reads in the
data and parses it.
You've all done more complicated
parsing of data
files than this.
So I won't belabor
the details.
I called it get data rather than
get spring data, because
I'm going to use the same
thing for a lot of
other kinds of data.
And the only thing I want you
to notice, is that it's
returning a pair of arrays.
OK, not lists.
The usual thing is, I'm building
them up using lists,
because lists have append and
arrays don't, and then I'm
converting them to arrays so
I can do matrix kinds of
operations on them.
So I'll get the distances
and the forces.
And then I'm just going to plot
them, and we'll see what
they look like.
So let's do that.
There they are.
Now, if you believe Hooke's Law,
you could look at this
data, and maybe you
wouldn't like it.
Because Hooke's Law implies
that, in fact, these points
should lie in a straight
line, right?
If I just plug in values here,
what am I going to get?
A straight line, right?
I'm just multiplying
k times x.
But I don't have a straight
line, I have a little scatter
of points, kind of it looks
like a straight
line, but it's not.
And why do you think
that's true?
What's going on here?
What could cause this line
not to be straight?
Have any you ever done
a physics experiment?
And when you did it, did your
results actually match the
theory that your high
school teacher, say,
explained to you.
No, and why not.
Yeah, you have various kinds of
experimental or measurement
error, right?
Because, when you're doing these
experiments, at least
I'm not perfect, and I suspect
at least most of you are not
perfect, you get mistakes.
A little bit of error creeps
in inevitably.
And so, when we acquired this
data, sure enough there was
measurement error.
And so the points are
scattered around.
This is something
to be expected.
Real data almost never matches
the theory precisely.
Because there usually is some
sort of experimental error
that creeps into things.
So what should we
do about that?
Well, what usually people do,
when they think about this, is
they would look at this data
and say, well, let me fit a
line to this.
Somehow, say, what would
be the line that best
approximates these points?
And then the slope of
that line would give
me the spring constant.
So that raises the next
question, what do I mean by
finding a line that best
fits these points?
How do we, fit, in this case,
a line, to the data?
First of all, I should ask the
question, why did I say let's
fit a line?
Maybe I should have said, let's
fit a parabola, or let's
fit a circle?
Why should I had said
let's fit a line.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, how
do I know that the
plot is a linear function?
Pardon?
Well, so, two things.
One is, I had a theory.
You know, I had up there a
model, and my model suggested
that I expected it
to be linear.
And so if I'm testing my model,
I should and fit a
line, my theory, if you will.
But also when I look at it, it
looks kind of like a line.
So you know, if I looked at it,
and it didn't look like a
line, I might have said, well,
my model must be badly broken.
So let's try and see
if we can fit it.
Whenever we try and fit
something, we need some sort
of an objective function
that captures the
goodness of a fit.
I'm trying to find, this is an
optimization problem of the
sort that we've looked
at before.
I'm trying to find a
line that optimizes
some objective function.
So a very simple objective
function here, is called the
least squares fit.
I want to find the line that
minimizes the sum of
observation sub i, the i'th data
point I have, minus what
the line, the model, predicts
that point should have been,
and then I'll square it.
So I want to minimize
this value.
I want to find the line
that gives me the
smallest value for this.
Why do you think I'm squaring
the difference?
What would happen if I didn't
square the difference?
Yeah?
Positive and negative errors
might cancel each other out.
And in judging the quality of
the fit, I don't really care
deeply -- you're going to get
very fat the way you're
collecting candy here --
I don't care deeply whether the
error is, which side, it
is, just that it's wrong.
And so by squaring it, it's
kind of like taking the
absolute value of the error,
among other things.
All right, so if we look
at our example here,
what would this be?
I want to minimize, want to find
a line that minimizes it.
So how do I do that?
I could easily do it
using successive
approximation, right?
I could choose a line, basically
what I am, is I'm
choosing a slope, here, right?
And, I could, just like Newton
Raphson, do successive
approximation for awhile,
and get the best fit.
That's one way to do
the optimization.
It turns out that for this
particular optimization
there's something
more efficient.
You can actually, there is a
closed form way of attacking
this, and I could explain
that, but in fact, I'll
explain something even better.
It's built into Pylab.
So Pylab has a function built-in
called polyfit.
Which, given a set of points,
finds the polynomial that
gives you the best
least squares
approximation to those points.
It's called polynomial because
it isn't necessarily going to
be first order, that
is to say, a line.
It can find polynomials
of arbitrary degree.
So let's look at the example
here, we'll see how it works.
So let me uncomment it.
So I'm going to get k and b
equals Pylab dot polyfit here.
What it's going to do is, think
about a polynomial.
I give you a polynomial of
degree one, you have all
learned that it's a x plus b,
b is the constant, and x is
the single variable.
And so I multiply a by x and I
add b to it, and as I vary x I
get new values.
And so polyfit, in this case,
will take the set of points
defined by these two arrays and
return me a value for a
and a value for b.
Now here I've assigned a to k,
but don't worry about that.
And then, I'm gonna now generate
the predictions that
I would get from this k
and b, and plot those.
So let's look at it.
So here it said the k is 31.475,
etc., and it's plotted
the line that it's found.
Or I've plotted the line.
You'll note, a lot of the points
don't lie on the line,
in fact, most of the points
don't lie on the line.
But it's asserting that
this is the best it
can do with the line.
And there's some points, for
example, up here, that are
kind of outliers, that are
pretty far from the line.
But it has minimized the error,
if you will, for all of
the points it has.
That's quite different from,
say, finding the line that
touches the most
points, right?
It's minimizing the
sum of the errors.
Now, given that I was just
looking for a constant to
start with, why did I bother
even plotting the data?
I happen to have known before
I did this that polyfit
existed, and what I was really
looking for was this line.
So maybe I should have just
done the polyfit and said
here's k and I'm done.
Would that have been
a good idea?
Yeah?
STUDENT: You can't know without
seeing the actual data
how well it's actually
fitting it.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Exactly right.
That says, well how would I know
that it was fitting it
badly or well, and in fact,
how would I know that my
notion of the model is sound,
or that my experiment isn't
completely broken?
So always, I think, always
look at the real data.
Don't just, I've seen too many
papers where people show me
the curve that fits the data,
and don't show me the data,
and it always makes
me very nervous.
So always look at the data,
as well as however you're
choosing to fit it.
As an example of that, let's
look at another set of inputs.
This is not a spring.
It's the same get data function
as before, ignore
that thing at the top.
I'm going to analyze it
and we'll look at it.
So here I'm plotting the speed
of something over time.
So I plotted it, and I've done
a least squares fit using
polyfit just as before to get a
line, and I put the line vs.
the data, and here I'm
a little suspicious.
Right, I fit a line, but when
I look at it, I don't think
it's a real good fit
for the data.
Somehow modeling this data as a
line is probably not right.
A linear model is not
good for this data.
This data is derived
from something, a
more complex process.
So take a look at it, and tell
me what order were calling of
polynomial do you think
might fit this data?
What shape does this
look like to you?
Pardon?
STUDENT: Quadratic.
PROFESSOR: Quadratic, because
the shape is a what?
It's a parabola.
Well, I don't know if I
dare try this one all
the way to the back.
Ooh, at least I didn't
hurt anybody.
All right, fortunately it's just
as easy to fit a ravel
parabola as a line.
So let's look down here.
I've done the same thing, but
instead of passing it one, as
I did up here as the argument,
I'm passing it two.
Saying, instead of fitting a
polynomial of degree one, fit
a polynomial of degree two.
And now let's see what
it looks like.
Well, my eyes tell me this
is a much better
fit than the line.
So again, that's why I wanted
to see the scatter plot, so
that I could at least look at
it with my eyes, and say,
yeah, this looks like
a better fit.
All right, any question about
what's going on here?
What we've been looking at is
something called linear
regression.
It's called linear because the
relationship of the dependent
variable y to the independent
variables is assumed to be a
linear function of
the parameters.
It's not because it has to
be a linear function of
the value of x, OK?
Because as you can see, we're
not getting a line, we're
getting a parabola.
Don't worry about the details,
the point I want to make is,
people sometimes see the word
linear regression and think it
can only be used
to find lines.
It's not so.
So when, for example, we did the
quadratic, what we had is
y equals a x squared
plus b x plus c.
The graph vs. x will not be a
straight line, right, because
I'm squaring x.
But it is, just about, in this
case, the single variable x.
Now, when I looked at this, I
said, all right, it's clear
that the yellow curve is a
better fit than the red.
It's a red line.
But that was a pretty
informal statement.
I can actually look at this
much more formally.
And we're going to look at
something that's the
statisticians call r squared.
Which in the case of a linear
regression is the coefficient
of determination.
Now, this is a big fancy word
for something that's actually
pretty simple.
So what r squared its going
to be, and this is on your
handout, is 1 minus e e over d
v. So e e is going to be the
errors in the estimation.
So I've got some estimated
values, some predicted values,
if you will, given to me by the
model, either the line or
the parabola in this case.
And I've got some real values,
corresponding to each of those
points, and I can look at the
difference between the 2 And
that will tell me how much
difference there is between
the estimated data and the,
well, between the predicted
data and the measured
data, in this case.
And then I want to divide that
by the variance in the
measured data.
The data variance.
How broadly scattered the
measured points are.
And I'll do that by comparing
the mean of the measured data,
to the measured data.
So I get the average value of
the measured data, and I look
at how different the points
I measure are.
So I just want to give to you,
informally, because I really
don't care if you understand
all the math.
What I do want you to
understand, when someone tells
you, here's the r squared value,
is, informally what it
really is saying.
It's attempting to capture the
proportion of the response
variation explained by the
variables in the model.
In this case, x.
So you'll have some amount of
variation that is explained by
changing the values
of the variables.
So if, actually, I'm going to
give an example and then come
back to it more informally.
So if, for example, r squared
were to equal 0.9, that would
mean that approximately 90
percent of the variation in
the variables can be explained
by the model.
OK, so we have some amount of
variation in the measured
data, and if r squared is 0.9,
it says that 90 percent can be
explained by the models, and the
other 10 percent cannot.
Now, that other 10 percent could
be experimental error,
or it could be that, in
fact, you need more
variables in the model.
That there are what are called
lurking variables.
I love this term.
A lurking variable is something
that actually
effects the result, but is not
reflected in the model.
As we'll see a little bit
later, this is a very
important thing to worry about,
when you're looking at
experimental data and you're
building models.
So we see this, for example,
in the medical literature,
that they will do some
experiment, and they'll say
that this drug explains
x, or has this affect.
And the variables they are
looking at are, say, the
disease the patient has, and
the age of the patient.
Well, maybe the gender of the
patient is also important, but
it doesn't happen to
be in the model.
Now, if when they did a fit,
it came out with 0.9, that
says at worst case, the
variables we didn't consider
could cause a 10
percent error.
But, that could be big, that
could matter a lot.
And so as you get farther from
1, you ought to get very
worried about whether
you actually have
all the right variables.
Now you might have the right
variables, and just experiment
was not conducted well, But it's
usually the case that the
problem is not that, but that
there are lurking variables.
And we'll see examples
of that.
So, easier to read than the
math, at least by me, easier
to read than the math, is the
implementation of r square.
So it's measured and estimated
values, I get the diffs, the
differences, between the
estimated and the measured.
These are both arrays, so I
subtract 1 array from the
other, and then I square it.
Remember, this'll do an
element-wise subtraction, and
then square each element.
Then I can get the mean, by
dividing the sum of the array
measured by the length of it.
I can get the variance, which is
the measured mean minus the
measured value, again squared.
And then I'll return
1 minus this.
All right?
So, just to make sure we sort
of understand the code, and
the theory here as well, what
would we get if we had
absolutely perfect prediction?
So if every measured point
actually fit on the curb
predicted by our model, what
would r square return?
So in this case, measured and
estimated would be identical.
What gets return by this?
Yeah, 1.
Exactly right.
Because when I compute it, it
will turn out that these two
numbers will be the, I'll get
0, 1 minus 0 is 0, right?
Because the differences
will be zero.
OK?
So I can use this, now, to
actually get a notion of how
good my fit is.
So let's look at speed dot pi
again here, and now I'm going
to uncomment these two things,
where I'm going to, after I
compute the fit, I'm going
to then measure it.
And you'll see here that the r
squared error for the linear
fit is 0.896, and for the
quadratic fit is 0.973.
So indeed, we get a much
better fit here.
So not only does our eye tell
us we have a better fit, our
more formal statistical measure
tells us we have a
better fit, and it tells
us how good it is.
It's not a perfect fit,
but it's a pretty
good fit, for sure.
Now, interestingly enough, it
isn't surprising that the
quadratic fit is better
than the linear fit.
In fact, the mathematics of
this should tell us it can
never be worse.
How do I know it can
never be worse?
That's just, never is a
really strong word.
How do I know that?
Because, when I do the quadratic
fit, if I had
perfectly linear data, then this
coefficient, whoops, not
that coefficient, wrong, this
coefficient, could be 0.
So if I ask it to do a quadratic
fit to linear data,
and the a is truly perfectly
linear, this coefficient will
be 0, and my model will turn
out to be the same as the
linear model.
So I will always get at
least as good a fit.
Now, does this mean that it's
always better to use a higher
order polynomial?
The answer is no, and
let's look at why.
So here what I've done is, I've
taken seven points, and
I've generated, if you look at
this line here, the y-values,
for x in x vals, points
dot append x
plus some random number.
So basically I've got something
linear in x, but I'm
perturbing, if you will, my
data by some random value.
Something between 0 and 1 is
getting added to things.
And I'm doing this so my
points won't lie on a
perfectly straight line.
And then we'll try and
fit a line to it.
And also, just for fun, we'll
try and fit a fifth order
polynomial to it.
And let's see what we get.
Well, there's my line, and
there's my fifth order
polynomial.
Neither is quite perfect, but
which do you think looks like
a closer fit?
With your eye.
Well, I would say the red line,
the red curve, if you
will, is a better fit, and sure
enough if we look at the
statistics, we'll see it's 0.99,
as opposed to 0.978.
So it's clearly a closer fit.
But that raises the very
important question: does
closer equal better, or tighter,
which is another word
for closer?
And the answer is no.
It's a tighter fit, but it's not
necessarily better, in the
sense of more useful.
Because one of the things I
want to do when I build a
model like this, is
have something
with predictive power.
I don't really necessarily need
a model to tell me where
the points I've measured lie,
because I have them.
The whole purpose of the model
is to give me some way to
predict where unmeasured points
would lie, where future
points would lie.
OK, I understand how the spring
works, and I can guess
where it would be if things
I haven't had the time to
measure, or the ability
to measure.
So let's look at that.
Let's see, where'd
that figure go.
It's lurking somewhere.
All right, we'll just
kill this for now.
So let's generate some more
points, and I'm going to use
exactly the same algorithm.
But I'm going to generate
twice as many points.
But I'm only fitting it
to the first half.
So if I run this one,
figure one is what
we looked at before.
The red line is fitting
them a little better.
But here's figure two.
What happens when I extrapolate
the curve to the
new points?
Well, you can see, it's
a terrible fit.
And you would expect that,
because my data was basically
linear, and I fit in non-linear
curve to it.
And if you look at it you can
see that, OK, look at this, to
get from here to here, it
thought I had to take off
pretty sharply.
And so sure enough, as I get
new points, the prediction
will postulate that it's still
going up, much more steeply
than it really does.
So you can see it's a
terrible prediction.
And that's because what I've
done is, I over-fit the data.
I've taken a very high degree
polynomial, which has given me
a good close fit, and I can
always get a fit, by the way.
If I choose a high enough degree
polynomial, I can fit
lots and lots of data sets.
But I have reason to
be very suspicious.
The fact that I took a fifth
order polynomial to get six
points should make
me very nervous.
And it's a very important
moral.
Beware of over-fitting.
If you have a very complex
model, there's a good chance
that it's over-fit.
The larger moral is, beware of
statistics without any theory.
You're just cranking away, you
get a great r squared, you say
it's a beautiful fit.
But there was no real
theory there.
You can always find a fit.
As Disraeli is alleged to have
said, there are three kinds of
lies: lies, damned lies,
and statistics.
And we'll spend some more time
when we get back from
Thanksgiving looking at how
to lie with statistics.
Have a great holiday,
everybody.